au terme de cette longue séquence
électorale de mise en place des
institutions pour le quinquennat qui
vient le peuple s'est exprimé
surmontant l'obstacle d'un mode de
scrutin particulièrement injuste et
inadapté aux valeurs de notre temps il a
décidé d'envoyer un très puissant groupe
parlementaire de députés rassemblement
national à l'assemblée
[Applaudissements]
qui devient ainsi un peu plus nationale
ce groupe sera de très loin le plus
nombreux de l'histoire de notre famille
politique
j'adresse toute ma gratitude aux
électeurs qui leur ont témoigné leur
confiance
cette confiance nous oblige nous avons
atteint les 3 objectifs que nous nous
étions fixés
faire des manuels macro un président
minoritaire de manière à préserver le
pays du règne d'un parti unique et d'un
président sans contrôle dans l'exercice
du pouvoir avec le risque que nous lui
connaissons d'en abuser pour suivre la
recomposition politique indispensable au
ressourcement démocratique et au seuil
du troisième millénaire pris en otage
par le mondialisme assumer le triomphe
de l' idée salvatrice de nation enfin de
constituer un groupe d'opposition
déterminant face aux des constructeurs
d'en haut les maquereaux nist et au des
constructeurs d'en bas cette extrême
gauche anti républicaine nous
incarnerons une opposition ferme c'est à
dire sans connivence mais une opposition
responsable
c'est à dire respectueuse des
institutions est toujours constructif
parce que notre seul et unique boussole
est l'intérêt de la france et du peuple
français
[Applaudissements]
ce nouveau groupe parlementaire national
et républicain aura à coeur dans
l'esprit de rassemblement national que
nous portons d'associer tous les élus et
mouvements politiques qui souhaitent
avec nous participer au redressement du
pays avec ses dizaines et ses dizaines
de députés de coeur et de conviction du
rassemblement national qui sont d'abord
des citoyens français soucieux du bien
public vous aurez la certitude de voir
défendu au parlement vos idées sur
l'immigration la sécurité le chômage la
justice fiscale et sociale
les territoires oubliés les citoyens
maltraités ou la démocratie bafouée
[Applaudissements]
et nouveau visage
les nouveaux visages que vous allez
découvrir des visages rayonnants
d'enthousiasmé de vie sont l'avant-garde
de cette nouvelle élite politique qui
prendra la responsabilité du pays
lorsque l' aventure macro aura pris fin
au delà du groupe parlementaire nous
allons poursuivre le travail de
rassemblement des français ou sans un
grand mouvement populaire unifiant tous
les patriotes de droite et de gauche un
rassemblement national pour défendre le
pays face à un effondrement que nous
constatons chaque jour et quand les
français le déciderons d'engager le
redressement dans la france a urgemment
besoin j'appelle tous les français d'où
qu'ils viennent quelle que soit leur
origine quelle que soit leur situation
personnelle ou professionnelle à nous
rejoindre dans cette aventure prat
ternel et exaltante qui s'appelle la
france notre seule ambition est de
servir les français nous nous battons
pour eux pour nos enfants pour le pays
vive la république vive la france
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]